it's a very strange question honestly
for me but I would want to marry
somebody that I see building I if I'm
with my boyfriend now and I see marrying
him one day if we get to that point
because he is a good partner he helps me
do certain things and I help him and I I
would it's easier to live life with
somebody
but that's not like my end goal like I'm
not gonna put everything on the side so
I can like live life with someone but
you know when you're grocery shopping
it's nice to do it with someone I don't
know if that answers your answer is like
look I'm gonna be a good partner I'm
gonna bring mine I'm gonna bring
something to the table but you're gonna
bring something to the table Yeah but
we're gonna do this together yeah and
also like I always like him and I
currently like we
the things that he's good at I'm not and
vice versa and also like I totally agree
a woman should be able to make a home
because guys don't really know how to
make a home yeah they don't know how to
how to decorate the apartment they don't
know the flowers are nice in the
apartment they don't know that like your
utensils should match and [__] so like
you know I'm guilty of all that by the
way yeah
um Ali why would a man why did your
husband want to marry you why wouldn't
he marry me no I'm kidding so it's
basically my perspective on marriage is
a little bit interesting being in that
feminine role where I fully depend on my
husband I believe that gives him purpose
so I think that he's had a greater sense
of appreciation for the work that he
does so it's more fulfilling and he can
cope with the stress more because well
you know he's doing it for me and he's
coming home to me also I make sure that
he's rewarded for his hard work and his
efforts he pretty much can lean on me in
times of trouble but also we can also
enjoy each other in times of great joy
and that's that's a really fun thing a
lot of people don't know this my husband
was a 50 year old Bachelor and well 48
year old Bachelor when I met him so he
he tells me even now that I add value to
his life and when I think about marriage
as a business it's like you know
Drummond Incorporated how can I make our
our brand our family our business how
can I make it so that we can Thrive how
much bigger can we make this German
household name and that's my approach to
marriage so I if if you want a really
good hard worker as life like that's
what I think I bring to them got it um
follow-up question before we get to
Pearl
you said your husband when you met him
he was 48 yes and now he's 50. so you've
been married give or take two years
together two years was he successful
before he met you
it was very successful oh yes yes I hung
out at the finish line and I got a
winner but that's a thing I do think
it's a thing and so Eric can you turn me
up a little bit I'm down a little bit so
when I met him he was very accomplished
in the military that that's the thing is
a lot of women wouldn't think that my
husband makes enough money but I'm a
badge bunny I'm like a masculinity honey
that's what I'm looking for what is a
badge money a badge money is a woman who
likes cops firefighters service members
so a man in uniform yes yes a man in
uniform so he's a a major and he's got
all these shiny medals and I'm like sir
sir pick me marry me choose me and yeah
so I know that a lot of women wouldn't
think that he makes enough but we live
in the midwest so it's like more than
enough money to go around and then you
know I've got the muscles to make up for
it so there you go um all right pearl
why would a man want to marry you
um I I do my best to be an asset in a
guy's life in whatever way that I can so
with my last boyfriend I was always like
cooking and cleaning um and I'd like
manage some of his business stuff so
when I when I'm like going into a
relationship I just want to I always
think about like what can I do to help
this guy like
life be easier day to day I think that's
what every part you should every if
you're in a partnership you should
always try to find
I feel like yeah some it got Eric if you
can hear me is the volume that's a train
yeah okay but so we're good on the
volume we're good okay gotcha because we
all see things sound a little low yeah
all of us so I don't know if you can
turn that up as you were I'm sorry what
would you how did you finish I forgot I
was just saying that I think it's
important to be an asset to a guy's life
yeah I I definitely agree with women
being in a relationship and you don't
have I'm definitely not for splitting
Bill bills and all that but you need to
contribute you need to be of a value but
not just in a relationship in in life
like if you if you're with a partner you
should do stuff together like okay maybe
he's cooking you said you were cooking
and cleaning was he doing anything or he
was just um
there no he was he was doing other
things okay well yeah can I can I give a
follow-up with you yeah and you tell me
yo hey that's too personal hey I don't
know I want to go there but you know Ali
married the guy that she was dating Coco
plans on marrying I guess the guy that
you're dating that's something you
envision but you were being an asset to
your relationship cooking cleaning being
an asset but you didn't end up marrying
him so is that like you know I kind of
was being the asset but it didn't work
out so I kind of regret it um I don't
regret that no um I mean I think I could
have had that if I want I just didn't
see it long term
um so did you break up with him or he
broke up with you oh you ended it yeah I
just didn't see it long term
um and I was I just I think a lot of
girls waste their 20s with guys that are
like boyfriends and not husbands and I
just didn't want to do that
um so yeah I ended that but I don't
regret doing that because I think one it
gave me like relationship skills so I
understand a little bit better like how
I can help a guy in the future let's
talk about this girls wasting their 20s
okay and how old are you by the way I'm
25. you're 25. yes you are 27 28 Coco 31
31 okay so you guys are mid-20s early
30s
um I've been very vocal about this I'll
as a guy waste your 20s as much as you'd
like your 20s are your time to [__] up
make mistakes do stupid stuff date the
wrong girl as a guy it's you're able to
do that as a girl
you can do that in your early 20s you do
not want to do that in your late 20s
okay
um let's talk about that why is it
important for a girl to actually not
waste their 20s well your value
decreases as a woman the older you get
and your opportunity to give a man
children
um it's less and less the older you get
yeah you can have IVF but most guys
don't want to spend like what is it 30k
16k 16k yeah I work most of the time
yeah so I mean if a guy can pick you
know a 35 year old woman or a 25 year
old woman he's gonna pick the 25 year
old woman you think so yeah why because
of the ability to be for fertile yeah
partially and like men they surveyed men
between the ages of like 20 and 80 and
all of them prefer girls around the age
of 22 23. yeah this is what role it was
saying yeah sexual the sexual
Marketplace so um I mean I think there's
other things sexual market value I don't
want to mess that up yeah I mean I think
there's other things that come into play
but I think men when it comes to
building a family and you also have the
issue of you know the more relationships
that a girl has been in the more
traumatized she's going to be a lot of
the more access she has to complain
about yeah and that just happens the
older you get well let me let me
actually give you a different side of
the coin because I remember you were
very um
open about this you said you are so much
better of a woman as a female as a
girlfriend at 30 31 as you were at 24.
yeah explain why I feel in your 20s you
just you're starting to learn who you
are and you see what you like when you
dislike and I think that in your 20s
you shouldn't be dating somebody like if
you're 21 22 you should not be in a
relationship for like five years I think
you should if it happens great good for
you but I think that you should explore
who you are as a person and by that you
can also date multiple guys so you can
see what you like when you're dislike so
you think that a woman who's 21 22 she
gets out of college she should go
through her whole face never said that I
said it you did no I never said you
should go through a whole phase you said
date multiple guys so I did not say it
has to be oh but we know what I mean I
think you should live your life and see
who you are so then later on